Yeah,
no,
not at all.
I think a lot of people don't understand
this at all.
First of all,
understand that in the state of New
York,
there has been very active conservative
party for decades,
uh,
elected Senator Buckley in the
seventies.
And if you look at the history of
congressional races in New York,
probably a lot of other races I've seen
through congressional races,
the Conservative Party oftentimes
nominates a person historically,
they've been the good sports that have
been willing to step back and throw
their support to the Republicans in the
interest of stopping a more Liberal
Democrat from getting in office.
Now,
what happened in New York,
23rd was a handful of people got into a
back room and nominated a democrat.
And the first thing we heard,
for example in my shop at freedom works
was from our grassroots activists in the
north country of New York.
They said,
the Republicans have just lost this
race.
Uh,
this woman can't possibly win this race.
She would not ever want a republican
primary.
She was too liberal.
If there's no way she would have won the
Republican primary.
So.
So what happened was the conservative
party said,
oh my gosh,
the Republicans are about to lose his
race,
uh,
and they feel that their candidate.
So what happened was there were three
candidates from three different parties
in the race to liberals in the
Republican and Democrat nominees,
and one conservative,
the conservative candidate,
although he was a first time candidate,
a quite naive and innocent in the ways
of politics.
He,
he grew so fast in his standing with the
electorate that she got knocked out of
the race when she got knocked out of the
race.
What did she do?
She made a deal with the White House and
Chuck Schumer and endorsed a Democrat.
So what did I say?
First validation.
I see aneurysm are grassroots activists
called that correctly,
didn't they?
They did.
In fact,
nominated Democrats and the Conservative
Party failed to win that election.
Now,
this is a short term victory for the
Republicans.
They can celebrate it all they want
because a year from now,
they're,
the Democrats will lose that seat
because the Republicans will have an
open primary.
They'll nominate a conservative
Republican or at least a middle of the
road Republican,
and that person will win the race back
from the Democrats so that Democrat will
only sit in that office for about a year
and when that happens,
the Conservative Party will once again
play their role of being in support of
their principals and working the
republican nominee a little bit more to
their perspective on public and,
and then helping him beat the Democrat.
Social issues were so much.
So I was up there.
I mean socialists were just simply not
part of the debate in that race.
The Democrat candidate,
when it was just the two of them and
erase the Democrat,
was running a gastro as a big spender.
And so her,
her first dress Greshon,
whereas she was four,
she was four big budgets.
She was for cap and trade.
She was for a card check.
The Mandatory Union plan that denied
workers' a secret ballad.
Uh,
so she,
she took on economic issues,
eras and I,
I saw no discussion of social issues in
that race on economic issues.
She was so liberal that even the
Democrat was running against her for
being too liberal at some point.
Everybody who are seeking office or
wanting to hold office at some point
they have to respond to the voting
constituency whose votes they want.
And right now the Republicans are in
office,
are kind of confused about that.
This,
this tea party movement,
which is what you see right now is most
visible and grassroots conservativism is
a thousand points of entrepreneurial
light into it.
In,
in a,
uh,
advocate,
advocating small government,
conservative Islam just popped up all
over the country.
Uh,
and it is genuine.
He largest grassroots movement I've ever
seen on a,
on particularly the economic issues.
The office holders are start,
oh,
I get it.
If I want to be reelected,
I better be responsive to what these
guys are telling me.
That's where all the energy,
there is no greater source of energy in
public policy,
discourse and politics today.
Then the small government conservative.
So the,
the Orthodox Republican Party is
dispirited and confused and going
through a massive identity crisis where
they're trying to.
Jay Basically ask the question is,
who are we and what are we doing here?
The Democrats are inflicted with
probably the most severe case of buyer's
remorse they ever had,
even worse than with the Clintons and 93
and 94 a day,
they have no energy to bring to the
field,
so the field is right now dominated by
the extremely big tent.
I was small government conservativism,
which has Democrats,
Republicans,
independents,
Libertarians,
evangelicals,
people of all stripes and color,
and I'm religious orientation,
and they're all happily joined in
resistance to a growth in the power of
the state that they find frightening for
their personal liberty.